three
ten joe biden ten
nine out of ten
six
six and a half uh negative fifty
with handling and coving i would
probably give him a seven he's doing all
that he possibly can but we have to
continue to go slow to go fast and so
working with the senate working with
house of reps to get get to get things
going of course also working with his
advisors as well um so i would give him
a seven with that six and a half
eight
i mean he's doing a not a good job but i
mean who could really do a good job in
these situations
i think the roll out of the vaccine has
been very effective there have been a
lot of hurdles that have come at him but
ultimately we're doing the best we can
get the booster
i feel like he's not doing enough to
like stop it because you know you heard
of the new uh variant that's you know
spiking in new york and everything like
that so i'm like there's no there's
nothing that he's really doing to stop
it from spreading everywhere else
communication he is a very good in
communication in
you know sending messages especially
like accurate ones with the science
backing up the information so i think
it's very good in communicating
everything that we have to do and
prepare ourselves for coving so he's
doing a great job in my opinion 10.
maybe like a three
i would say between a two and a three
because you know he should have he
should have been faster to get um twelve
year olds and like
that uh other people under 12 year olds
old vaccinated he could have done a
better job maybe we wouldn't be in the
position we are now or even like for
like when the 16 16 like under 16 could
get vaccinated that could have been done
earlier i think yeah then we would have
been the better position probably than
we are now
i feel like he's not mentally there and
he's very unstable so he's not fit to
run for he's not fit to be president